[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
ici à bruxelles au parlement européen
c'est parti pour 30 minutes de
décryptage de l'actualité dans cette
émission direction l'irlande le 29 mars
2017 londres active à l'article 50 pour
sortir de l'union européenne un an plus
tard la question de la frontière entre
irlande du nord et république d'irlande
se pose toujours et ravive une histoire
traumatique reportages et débats à
suivre mais d'abord l'actualité portée
par la france l'idée de soumettre les
gaffes à les grandes entreprises du
numérique à l'impôt a fait son chemin
il ya quelques jours pierre moscovici le
commissaire aux affaires économiques a
fait des propositions en écoute
la commission propose donc aujourd'hui
d'intégrer les activités numériques dans
la définition de l'impôt sur les
sociétés au même titre que les activités
traditionnelles et par là même d'assurer
une égalité de traitement et une
taxation plus juste que proposons nous
concrètement très simplement ce que nous
proposons aux états membres
ce que nous proposons au parlement
européen c'est une définition juridique
de la présence numérique qui viendra
s'ajouter pas se substituer au concept
de présence physique dans les lois
nationales qui définissent l'impôt sur
les sociétés alors on change tout du sol
au plafond ou alors est-ce que ça va
suffire pour taxer véritablement les
gaffes à est-ce qu'on doit plutôt faire
converger nos systèmes d'imposition des
grandes entreprises et plus largement
comment réguler ces géants du net pour
en débattre j'ai le plaisir de recevoir
marc tarabella
bonjour vous êtes député revient vous
faites partie du groupe des socialistes
et démocrates vous êtes belge bienvenue
à vous en face de vous pascal durand
vous êtes vous
dans le groupe des verts et vous êtes
français enfin eric meurice vous êtes
rédacteur en chef du site
liu et observeur bienvenue à vous alors
messieurs cette taxe de 3% annoncée par
la commission européenne
est ce que c'est un bon début bons
débuts pardon ou est ce que c'est un
petit peu ridicule au vu de ce qu'on va
récolter c'est à dire 5 milliards
d'euros par an marc tarabella
prenons ce qui est pris c'est un beau
début pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui ce
qui est scandaleux c'est que les gars
femme ne paye quasi pas d'impôts sur un
chiffre d'affaires en 2010 est pour le
premier semestre estimé à plus de 600
milliards d'euros ça veut dire que en
europe aujourd'hui des pays font
obstacle à ce qu'ils aient une
harmonisation fiscale
il faut faire du naming name in chains
c'est le luxe il déclaré c'est de la
faute du luxembourg de lire lors de
chypre et de malte 4 denis pays de
l'union européenne qui vivent évidemment
de d'un taux de taxation ridiculement
bas pour attirer des entreprises chez
elle
les entreprises qui font un chiffre
d'affaires sur l'ensemble de l'union
européenne et qui ne sont pas taxés
réellement on rappelle qu'apple impayés
en moyenne 0 5 % d'impôt en néerlandais
et que du coup à la commission
européenne au 05 mai et donc au regard
de l'impôt que paye chaque citoyen c'est
évidemment c'est scandaleux donc
l'équité
aujourd'hui j'estime que dans le
contexte européen le rapport de force
politique
la proposition est un beau début parce
que c'est pas évident de faire évoluer
toute une série de pays parce qu'il faut
l'unanimité en fiscalité sur ces
questions pascal durand alain lamassoure
qui est ici au parlement européen
députés français avait rendu un rapport
sur ces questions et proposer quelque
chose de plus large de revoir
complètement l'assiette de l'impôt pour
les entreprises et donc il l'a parlait
dans le cadre de la proposition de la
commission européenne d'un pachyderme
qui a accouché d'une souris est ce que
vous êtes sur la même ligne non d'abord
je pense que pour une fois que la
commission bouge on va pas lui taper
dessus sert qu'on a suffisamment
reproché à la commission de ne rien
faire comme moment où elle commence à se
saisir enfin d'un sujet c'est bon donc
moi je veux pas lent
on sait j'observe que l'extrait que vous
avez passé de pierre moscovici concerne
uniquement les mesures à très court
terme c'est à dire qu'il a ils ont fait
deux plans d'une part le très court
terme
et il a raison c'est qu'en fait on
s'aperçoit qu'un certain nombre de pays
sont en train d'essayer de sauver leur
peau et donc de taxer de leur côté pas
dans une logique européenne
donc la commission dit dans un premier
temps prenons une mesure les 3%
c'est pas ridicule parce que pour une
fois ce n'est pas sur les bénéfices mais
sur le chiffre d'affaires sur les
recettes
donc c'est déjà pas négligeable et puis
effectivement il ya un deuxième aspect
qui va être sur le moyen et le long
terme
et là ça a été très justement dit par
marc tarabella il faut l'unanimité
donc ça va être un peu compliqué c'est
qu' il faut une assiette commune est
donc celle qu'avait proposé le parlement
à juste titre c'est qu'on taxe d'une
manière uniforme dont l'union européenne
pour ça il va falloir progresser petit
bout par petit bout
le parlement l'a voté la commission s'en
est saisi et donc maintenant on va
laisser faire le conseil et avec maurice
penser à quel point la france aaa
devrait depuis le mois de juillet
dernier comme bruno le maire a annoncé
cette idée de taxer les gaffes à à quel
point la france est derrière comment est
ce qu'on va pouvoir faire piliers des
pays comme le luxembourg comme l'irlande
comme malte
des arguments qui est mis en avant c'est
l'opinion publique en entendant marc
tarabella m pascal durand ça me fait
penser à la sphère luc slicks et au la
lutte contre l'évasion et l'optimisation
fiscale
les états qui résistaient sont obligés
petit à petit d'accepter le fait qu' on
ne peut pas rester
face la situation est finalement l'union
européenne réagit avec un peu de retard
sur la révolution numérique que ce soit
en termes de régulation en termes de
protection des consommateurs de
protection des données
là on arrive sur la question de la
taxation de ces entreprises
et ça s'inscrit dans une réflexion plus
globale de comment l'europe peut se
remettre dans cette course là comment
elle peut gérer ses gaffes à andy les
gars femmes et c'est évidemment beaucoup
plus large que ça comment on peut gérer
ces entreprises sur le marché européen
comme on peut gérer le marché européen
et donc il ya une réflexion globale avec
cette question de la taxation qui en
fait partie et les états comme le
luxembourg comme l'irlande l'irlande qui
rappelons le n'a pas voulu des 13
milliards d'apple que la commission
européenne
leon neal a fallu aller quasiment la
cour de justice pour ça c est a
finalement il commence à dire oui une
marge de compromis alors 5 milliards 3 %
ça peut paraître peu mais comme vous
l'avez dit c'est c'est de court terme et
la réflexion va prendre du temps
au premier étage il faut pas s'imaginer
que les états membres se mettre d'accord
dans l'année qui vient
mais la réflexion est là et je pense
qu'une prise de conscience il faut pas
oublier et ils vous le savez très bien
les oeufs et les élections européennes
arrive et ça fera probablement partie du
débat avec des arguments et ils n'ont pu
une opinion publique qui va probablement
faire plus pression sur les sur les
gouvernements
on est dans une mesure presque
symbolique je dirais effectivement un an
des élections européennes il fallait
montrer que l'union européenne se bouge
pour protéger entre guillemets les
européens et qui a une mesure d'équité
il ya un peu de ça c'est à dire qu'on
peut pas à la fois expliqué que les
budgets nationaux sont dans des
situations de précarité importantes pour
certains pays on peut pas constater que
les impôts sont lourds pour un grand
nombre d'artisans de petites entreprises
etc
et puis acceptée vous l'avez dit les 0 0
5% mais même les 8% alors la moyenne
c'est de 2 à 3 pour atteindre un taux
d'imposition sur ces entreprises dont
c'était gasag ainsi google facebook
amazon apple contre 23% pour exactement
ça mais en plus le fait qu'il peut
frauder sur quelque chose que nous
pouvons pas faire je dis le nous tout
les citoyens européens mais y compris
entreprises européennes c'est que quand
vous êtes dans un lieu
vous êtes taxé dans ce lieu en réalité
le numérique avait une capacité
extraordinaire a laissé son activité
dans des lieux parce que c'est
évidemment la france l'allemagne la
grande-bretagne qui sont les les grands
clients mais à côté de ça il y avait pas
de structure et les flux partait sur les
publicités sur tous ces sujets là on
partait en irlande à malte wire et
effectivement il y avait zéro taxation
derrière il ya un scandale qui intéresse
les européens depuis quelque temps c'est
la question de cambridge analytica donc
à une entreprise qui a siphonné des
données justement sur facebook et qui a
par ce biais là permis au camp de trump
notamment et à ce qu'on appelle la halle
trust américaines c'est à dire la droite
extrême et de remporter les élections on
parle également d'une manipulation
potentiel sur le référendum sur le break
site
le siphonage des données on sait que ça
fait aussi quelques temps en fait que la
commission européenne que les européens
se sont emparés de cette question il ya
d'ailleurs en fait une directive qui va
entrer en vigueur fin mai là en
attendant on est complètement à côté de
la plaque marc tarabella sur ce dossier
du contrôle de la régulation de nos
données et de la manière dont elles sont
utilisées pour manipuler l'opinion
on voit que nous nous battons je crois
en cela la manière de réagir au niveau
européen complètement différent de la
manière américaine où les données la
préservation des données
la data protection c'est quelque chose
qui nous parlent aux états unis c'est
d'abord le business il dit après peu
importe comment on obtient des données
et là je crois que c'est vraiment un
aujourd'hui ça pose au delà de la
question de l'utilisation des données
personnelles
c'est une question de démocratie qui est
posée même de la possibilité qu'ils
aient faire retourner l'opinion pour le
break si c'est pour le maxi pour les
élections américaines peut-être pour des
élections complètement à d'autres bout
de la planète où des gens se sont
adressés à cette entreprise qui
apparemment aurait dit mais écoutez vous
inquiétez pas on va compromettre dans un
scandale peut-être sexuelle votre
adversaire principal où est on là on est
complètement déni de démocratie
et je suis assez triste de voir que mark
zukerberg refuse d'aller s'exprimer
devant le parlement britannique il
envoie directeur technique de se faire
accompagner par ailleurs été invité ici
par antonio tajani devant le parlement
mais sans doute que son bébé
je vais laisser la passe lui échappe
complètement
mais ça pose un vrai problème de
démocratie et là je pense qu'on doit
vraiment tous sont inquiétés de cette
utilisation abusive des données à des
fins qui sont quand même voix bhl eric
meurice la directive je le disais qu'il
va entrer en ligne de compte sur la
protection des données fin mais est ce
qu'elle va nous protéger de ce genre de
siphonnage ou pas alors c'est le but
mais il faudra aller plus loin
d'ailleurs la commission européenne
commence à réfléchir à la commissaire du
rove a écrit au patron de facebook pour
avoir plus d'informations il est
question aussi de faire rentrer la
protection des données dans le droit des
consommateurs donc à une réflexion mais
surtout je crois que les termes du débat
politique ont changé ce que voient les
dirigeants européens on l'a vu lors du
dernier conseil européen c'est que
maintenant il ya un lien clair entre ces
questions qui pouvaient paraître
technique qui pourrait qui pouvait
paraître simplement limiter à la
protection des consommateurs
ça devient une question stratégique de
souveraineté comme dirait le président
macron aidant jeu démocratique
et lorsqu on écoutait les
des têtes gouvernement au conseil ils
font le lien maintenant entre les
attaques contre la sécurité de l'europe
et la question de la protection des
données donc là on passe d'une échelle
individuelle à une échelle ça jure
stratégie globale et ça ça pourrait
changer le débat est là ça devient très
intéressant parce que ça monte au sommet
politique de l'europe et ça sort des
discussions qu'on pourrait voilà prendre
quelque chose pour juste du technique
comment on va utiliser sa page
personnelle facebook
et voilà ça c'est intéressant aussi à
long terme de voir effectivement on
n'est pas assez là c'est une section où
la fin on est dans une forme de presse
que science fiction ce qu'ont imaginé
passer la capacité d'une entreprise via
notre aspiration de donner à manipuler
l'opinion
alors c'est exactement ce que vous dites
et est tout à fait juste à dire que là
on a une dimension complémentaire on
avait vu avec assange est un certain
nombre de lanceurs d alerte dans le
passé que les données pouvaient être
piratée notamment par la nsa et par des
services secrets ou des services de
défense
on nous avait expliqué à l'époque que
c'était oui c'était pas bien de prendre
ces données mais bon globalement c'était
pour la défense la lutte contre le
terrorisme les sécurités très bien fait
très bien jeudi à l'époque on nous avait
expliqué ça et là on passe un degré
supplémentaire puisqu'on s'aperçoit que
non seulement on nous prend nous donner
mais qu'on les utilise à des fins
commerciales dans un premier temps parce
que il faut bien comprendre que ça ça a
été fait déjà vendu la nsa est là rien
payé elle a piqué tandis que là on l'a
vendu donc déjà première premiers
éléments deuxième élément on les utilise
pour manipuler vous avez utilisé
exactement le bon terme pour manipuler
l'opinion publique c'est à dire qu'on
s'aperçoit que la société qui a joué à
ça c'est celle qui était dirigée par
monsieur steve banane c'est à dire par
le conseiller communication de donald
trump dans le cadre des élections
américaines et que donc on a eu un lien
direct entre des données qui sont soit
disant utilisé à des fins scientifiques
autres qui en réalité sont utilisés
directement directement pour permettre à
un candidat à la présidence de la
république ou pour permettre comme ça a
été dit en angleterre aux partisans du
livre et donc du bric site d'avoir des
informations particulières privilégiez
donc là c'est très très grave
on est
quasiment dans web encore une fois c'est
grâce à un lanceur d'alerté que ces
informations sont arrivés et que donc ça
renforce la nécessité pour l'europe de
développer ces directives sur le secret
des affaires versus la protection des
lanceurs d'alerté
c'est juste encore un point où la chance
que c'est effectivement un dossier qui
est en cours ' de chez les gauthier
seront annoncés parce que c'est à
l'assemblée nationale française alors 29
mars 2017 c'était il ya pile poil un an
londres active l'article 50 et envoie sa
lettre de divorce à l'union européenne
un an plus tard les négociations ont
avancé notamment sur le coût du divorce
et sur le maintien des droits des
citoyens
après le départ des britanniques mais il
demeure un flou c'est la question des
360 km de frontière entre l'irlande du
nord et république d'irlande un an après
à derry ville symbolique du conflit
irlandais la perspective du bric site
ravive de bien sombres souvenirs
c'est un reportage de fabien rey caire
[Musique]
les gens se sont réunis ici
la manifestation avait commencé dans les
quatre sur la colline il y avait entre
15 et 20 mille personnes un régiment de
parachutistes a suivi les gens jusqu'ici
ils ont commencé à tirer sur la foule
en 1972 la ville nord-irlandaise de
derry a été le théâtre du bloody sunday
une manifestation pour les droits
civiques de la minorité catholique est
réprimée dans le sang par l'armée
britannique
quatorze personnes sont tuées john kelly
participé à la manifestation avec son
frère c'est ici que le bloody sunday a
eu lieu et mon frère michael est mort ce
jour-là déry ville symbole du conflit
entre londres et les nationalistes
irlandais et surtout toute proche de la
frontière avec la république d'irlande
de l'autre côté du fleuve
c'est le comté de donegal en république
d'irlande par boîte on a une meilleure
vue comme vous voyez on est vraiment
proche celle et brighton
on est éleveur de père en fils depuis un
siècle kevin élève des bovins à viande
des deux côtés de la frontière
il a 2 170 vaches au royaume-uni 130 en
république d'irlande
pour l'instant toutes ses vaches sont
européennes nous arrivons à la frontière
vous voyez ces panneaux voilà c'est ici
nous voilà en république d'irlande
comme vous voyez la route est libre il
n'y a aucun obstacle
depuis les accords de paix de 1998
on circule librement entre des rideaux
n'égale une frontière invisible que cet
éleveur travers cinq à dix fois par
semaine mais kevin se souvient de
l'époque où la démarcation entre les
deux irlande et est lourdement gardé par
des soldats britanniques
ici c'était une zone fortifiée votre
véhicule était arrêté et vous pouviez
être retenu pendant une heure deux
heures la perspective du bric site
ravive de mauvais souvenirs chez kevin
brayson le rétablissement de la
frontière couperet son exploitation en
2nde frontières et des contrôles
entraînerait des ralentissements et des
coûts et sur le plan politique cela
créera des divisions là où l'on ne
devrait pas y en avoir
l'histoire nous enseigne que les
divisions ce n'est pas après le break
site
kevin devra faire une croix sur deux
tiers des aides européennes qu'il
perçoit aujourd'hui à derry tout le
monde redoute l'impact économique du
rétablissement de la frontière à l'image
de gavin câline
cet entrepreneur a racheté une
imprimerie en 2004 il emploie
aujourd'hui 40 personnes
il y à 18 mois kevin a investi près d'un
million d'euros dans cette imprimante
ultra modernes fabriquées au danemark
si on devait acheter cette machine en
étant à l'extérieur de l'union
européenne les taxes à l'import la
rendrait sans doute trop cher
aujourd'hui personne ne fabriquent ce
type de machine gavin apporte toute sa
matière première de l'union européenne
et réalise 40% de son chiffre d'affaires
avec la république d'irlande
le problème c'est l'incertitude
y aura-t-il une frontière des contrôles
douaniers les marchandises pour hôtels
circuler librement
nous ne savons pas certains de nos
clients en république d'irlande envisage
de ne plus se fournir au royaume uni
mais plutôt de se tourner vers des
fournisseurs dont l'union européenne oui
mais nous pourrions envisager de
délocaliser une partie de l'activité en
république d'irlande
ce qui est sûr c'est que le temps nous
est compté
gavin ignore à quoi ressemblera la
frontière après le break site
certains évoquent même le maintien de
l'irlande du nord dans le marché unique
mais pour ce député du parti unioniste
qui a fait campagne pour la sortie de
l'europe c'est hors de question
ses 14 derniers mois on a agité beaucoup
de peur nous devons dépasser cela ait
travaillé ensemble l'irlande du nord a
traversé beaucoup d'épreuves ces
quarante dernières années en termes de
violence et de terrorisme
et pourtant nos entreprises ont tenu le
cap le royaume uni est entré unis dans
lieux il doit en sortir unis
les nationalistes irlandais plaide quant
à eux pour une réunification des deux
irlande
en attendant les européens ont acté leur
refus du retour à une frontière physique
quitte à remettre en question
l'intégrité territoriale du royaume uni
[Musique]
et voilà pour ce reportage édifiant de
favières écart à la frontière entre les
deux irlande alors messieurs peut être
eric cette question de la frontière
irlandaise a été dès le début dans la
négociation entre britanniques et
européens en fait un point d'achoppement
où est-ce qu'on en est aujourd'hui sur
cette question-là l'impression que c'est
complètement inextricable c'est
inextricable
moi je dirais que c'est l'intrusion du
tragique de l'histoire dans
l'institutionnel européen s'est on a le
bring it on a réussi à régler la
question du droit des citoyens parce que
c'est du droit pur et dur on a réussi à
régler l'histoire du règlement financier
dubray de du président du divorce parce
que c'est de là c'est de la politique
ont négocié la frontière que ce que
c'est on l'a vu c'est c'est l'histoire
ces deux communautés qui ont été
séparées par la guerre jusqu'à ya 20 ans
et comment on n'imagine pas pour nous
une frontière ci ont montré notre
passeport pour aller de france en
belgique c'est un on faisait la queue
non là c'était c'était la guerre et
c'est comme si on établit c'est une
sorte de rideau de fer entre les deux et
c'est très difficile et l'un des deux
devra céder sinon la solution de
continuité c'est la continuation de
celle alignement comme on dit des règles
douanières ça veut dire d'entériner
l'unification de l'irlande économique et
ça c'est pas acceptable pour londres
donc là on est vraiment effectivement
quelque chose souveraineté du royaume
uni contre la souveraineté de l'irlande
sur soutenu par les 26 autres je vois
pas pour l'instant comment on peut s'en
sortir il n'y a aucune solution pascal
durand si celle qui est en train de se
faire il ya aucune solution si on
regarde la position donnée par les
britanniques parce qu'en fait tout part
dans le mensonge cirque on nous a
expliqué le nous ils ont expliqué les
partisans du break cite notamment
monsieur faradje et tous ses amis que
l'on pouvait être à la fois dedans et
dehors c'est à dire qu'en gros bas on
allait avoir les avantages mais pas les
inconvénients bah voyons
et donc là on s'aperçoit que leur
discours était un discours mensonger qui
a pas de solution sur leurs bases
en réalité là on s'oriente vers une
solution qui va être le pire de ce qui
pouvait arriver aux défenseurs du bric
site c'est à dire que pour ne pas
remettre en cause l'accord entre les
deux vies reland et ravivé effectivement
ces années sanglantes et et de
terrorisme et de d2 et de souffrance
ils vont être obligés à ce stade et
enfin vous m'expliquer comment soin de
faire tout sortir ce qui est
inimaginable pour l'irlande qui va
jamais accepter de sortir de l'union
européenne soit d'avoir les mêmes règles
partout et donc l'angleterre va se
retrouver avec l'obligation de respecter
l'ensemble des normes européennes pour
ne pas remettre de frontières entre les
deux irlande et entre le royaume uni et
l'irlande et en même temps ne pourra
plus participer aux décisions c'est à
dire ça sera en gros la position
actuelle de la norvège qui est soumis
aux règles de l'union européenne sans
jamais partie sans jamais parce qu'ils
descendent jamais voter c'est pour ça
que je dis que ça va être la pire des
solutions par rapport à eux
mais à ce stade et c'est d'ailleurs la
position exprimée par michel barnier
il n'y a pas d'autre solution
rationnelle possible que celle-ci marc
tarabella
les britanniques veulent sortir de
l'union douanière ça veut dire que de
fait il ya une frontière dur qui devrait
se remettre en place entre irlande du
nord et république d'irlande sauf que
l'idée justement et de surtout pas
remettre de frontières dur si sauf à
raviver effectivement ces années de
conflit est ce qu'une frontière molle
pour utiliser des termes pas très
juridique pourrait coller ou pas la
frontière molle pascal durand vient de
dire ce que c'est c'est le statut à la
norvégienne
c'est à dire conserver le droit à
l'accès au marché
le fait de l'appliquer aussi les
directives européennes comme les normes
les norvégiens le fonds pour les
directives marché intérieur mais ça ça a
un coût il faut payer une contribution
au budget européen et donc les partisans
du bric sites vont être pluie devant
leurs contradictions ce sont des
menteurs menteur d'abord par omission
qui n'ont jamais admis que le royaume
uni avait bénéficié du marché intérieur
pour rebooster leur économie dans le
reportage ici on a vu que le fait
d'abaisser les frontières fait que ce
tag riz culteurs et surtout cet
imprimeur ont leur majeure partie audio
une bonne partie le chiffre d'affaires à
l'extérieur de leur pays
parfait mais le problème c'est que ça un
coup on peut pas si vous allez en dehors
de l'union européenne et que vous voulez
les mêmes bénéfices mais plus rien à
payer et plus évidemment le problème et
est alors pourquoi l'allemagne reste
vraiment de l'union européenne hélas un
début de la fin de l'union européenne il
faut une plus value en étant dedans tout
est grossier excusez moi je suis belge
ou d'en permettre nous ont merdé pendant
quatre ans
à faire l'europe à la carte et à la
promotionner est aujourd'hui qui veulent
partir ils nous emmerdent encore en
voulant faire la sortie à la carte
ça suffit quand même je pense que
heureusement michel barnier michel
barnier quelqu'un qui connaît qui est un
négociateur efficace et j'espère que et
jusqu'à présent le front européen
jusqu'à quand il s'agit pas de vengeance
ni ni de punition il le dit très bien
michel barnier mais cette négociation il
faut savoir où on est dehors on est
dedans
est ce que il faut vraiment avoir peur
d'une résurgence de cette guerre à la
frontière on sait que on a entendu que
le thin fine et est reparti dans ses
revendications d'une irlande
il faut avoir peur parce que les
unionistes fallait il ya vraiment c'est
une partie de l'extrême droite
britannique il faut pas ce sont des anti
européens mais pas simplement ce sont
aussi des xénophobes se sont globalement
c'est une partie très très dur
donc ils ont des groupes paramilitaires
et et en face il ya évidemment toute une
tradition une histoire de résistance à
l'occupation britannique
donc oui il faut avoir peur il faut
avoir peur qu'au sein même de l'union
européenne
on voit des conflits ce sera révisée et
et en plus il ya des questions sociales
très fortes et sera donc oui il faut
avoir peur il faut qu'on reste sur une
logique de démocratie dopés et données
de séries comme il ya deux faits
politiques à prendre en compte dans les
mois qui viennent jusqu'à normalement la
fin de la négo c'est octobre 1 les
unionistes theresa may dépend d'eux à
westminster pour avoir la majorité et de
sa fernand qu'on n'a pas de gouvernement
en irlande du nord qui est normalement
partagé entre les unionistes et les
républicains ça fait un an qu'ils se
disputent pour trouver un accord donc ça
fait une situation politique explosive
avec les radicaux qui pourrait redevenir
les principaux acteurs et ça rend encore
plus difficile non seulement trouver un
accord mais comme vous le dites ça rend
plus difficile de maintenir la paix en
cas d'échec des négociations
pan de toute façon on suivra bien
entendu ce dossier qui n'a pas fini de
nous occuper sur ces prochains mois
c'est tout de suite c'est l'heure du
checkpoint je suis sûr qu'il va vous
intéresser marque je ne sais pas
pourquoi mais cette semaine on se penche
sur le changement d'heure ah oui le
changement d'heure tout à fait
aujourd'hui il y habite ud sens et donc
nous faire dépenser moins
et qu'ils peuvent pour le coup tous nous
pourrir la vie alors même si on a pu
traîner plus longtemps à l' apéro en
terrasse ces dernières années eh oui et
oui tout à fait parce qu'on sait que ça
dure très longtemps jusqu'à 22 heures on
a du soleil donc on reste l'heure d'été
at elle encore des avantages c'est le
checkpoint de l'incroyable xavier
lambert et c'est tout de suite ya trop
de livres cette année notre dernier
passage à l'heure d'été le 7 février
dernier le parlement européen a voté une
résolution demandant la commission de
lancer une évaluation complète du
système actuel et si nécessaire de
présenter des propositions pour la
réviser pour la députée verte karima
delli à la base de la proposition
y a plus d'impact négatif sur la santé
la sécurité car on parlera peut-être
d'énergie tuteur que t'es fait positive
alors l'heure d'été at-elle plus
d'inconvénients que davantage non c'est
par les allemands 10 916 leurs dettes et
abandonnée en 1945 puis ré instaurer en
france en 1976
on est alors en pleine crise pétrolière
et le but est de faire des économies
d'énergie en france on n'a pas de
pétrole mais on a des zips en avançant
les montres d'une heure
ça permet au soleil de se coucher plus
tard et on n'a pas besoin d'utiliser
d'éclairage artificiel le soir on
consomme ainsi moins d'électricité
aussi bien dans les maisons que dans les
lieux publics selon l' agence de
l'environnement et de la maîtrise de
l'énergie
l'heure d'été aurait fait gagner à la
france 440 gigawatts d'électricité en
2009 soit l'équivalent d'une ville de
800 mille foyers
mais l'agencé admet qu'avec l'évolution
des technologies cette économie va
diminuer d'année en année d'autres
études ont eu même un bénéfice nul voire
négatif car des surconsommation de
chauffage et de climatisation qui a
ruiné les économies d'éclairage et puis
il y a des conséquences négatives sur la
santé comme le jour tombe plus tard on a
plus de mal à s'endormir changement
d'heure perturbe notre rythme biologique
et provoque une hausse des accidents
cardiaques mais aussi des des pressions
voire des suicides liées au manque de
sommeil
bien qu'il fasse plus clair le soir nos
routes ne sont pas plus sûr à l'heure
d'été par contre le retour à l'heure
d'hiver en train d'un important puits
d'accident le mois qui suit le
changement en 1997 un rapport du sénat
français l'affirmé clairement les
avantages annoncés ou attendues du
changement semestriel de leurs ne sont
pas suffisamment importants pour
proposer les inconvénients ressentie par
les populations et sondage montre
également que les opinions publiques
sont clairement défavorable à leur dit
alors qu'en karima delli qu'il y a plus
l'impact négatif que d'effets positifs à
l'heure d'été c'est plutôt vrai voilà
marc tarabella vous étiez vent debout
alors ça y est c'est fini l'heure d'été
non j'espère que non ce reportage est à
plaidoyer à sens unique négatif qui
donne la sinistrose
je rappeler à monsieur lambert qui a
fait le reportage que lorsqu'il ya plus
d'accidents au mois de novembre après le
changement d'heure fin octobre c'est
parce qu'il ya aussi les feuilles mortes
qui t'ont il fait plus humide et c'est
le début des périodes de jeu les
docteurs je pense que l'heure d'hiver
est bien adapté à l'hiver car le plus de
clarté que nous avons se répartit en ce
qui est à peu près le début la fin la
journée classique scolaire on va dire
mais en été c'est vraiment guerre de
passer à l'heure d'été
parce qu'il ya des avantages aussi je
pense aux personnes qui travaillent qui
ferment leur voler les commerçants à
18h30 19h et qui rendent chez nous
encore bien le droit de souffler et de
profiter un peu des rayons du soleil
couchant
ce qui est bon pour la santé d'ailleurs
la vitamine d est une des vitamines les
meilleurs pour la santé
et j'en ai ras le bol de ceux qui le
font les des négatifs société sinistrés
on encore plus à sinistrose alors le
l'image du revolver la marque n'est pas
d'accord on repassera pour vous à
l'heure d'été là l'épreuve lagarde ont
la garde
merci monsieur d'avoir été avec nous
aujourd'hui c'est la fin de cette
émission mais bien entendu vous pouvez
la revoir sur nos réseaux sociaux et sur
nos sites internet respectifs
rendez-vous dans quinze jours puisque la
semaine prochaine ses vacances avec
ahmed tazir ici à bruxelles très belle
semaine à tous ciao
[Musique]